ministre le général de gaulle aurait
sûrement qualifié la période depuis
novembre 2010 8,2 chienlit les gilets
jaunes depuis 14 mois des violences
perpétrés chaque semaine plus de 56
jours de grève
du jamais vu après le blocage des trains
des métros des bus ce sont aujourd'hui
les infirmiers des médecins qui menacent
de démissionner les enseignants les
policiers les pompiers des avocats qui
mettent leurs robes à terre les ports
sont bloqués des manifestations
syndicales à répétition des entreprises
en difficulté une économie lourdement
touché des commerçants qui n'en peuvent
plus ajoutons à cela une réforme des
retraites traiter avec un incroyable
amateurisme qui a généré de grande
inquiétude pour nos concitoyens
face à ces inquiétudes votre majorité a
fait preuve d'une grande arrogance et
d'une cacophonie anxiogène le résultat
est là depuis 14 mois
la chienlit est installé et les français
ont perdu confiance
monsieur le premier ministre quand et
comment comptez vous ramener très
rapidement la confiance et la sérénité
dans notre pays qui en a tant besoin
[Applaudissements]